[Music]
Um, we titled this talk the build
operate divide because we've observed
this troubling trend where like good AI
product concepts fail to reach their
full potential due to operational
challenges. So today, Chris and I are
going to be talking about some of the
learnings we've gleaned from like our
experiences on the front lines
operationalizing AI products at scale.
By the end of this talk, we hope you're
going to leave with an understanding of
how you can kind of bridge that gap
between product concept um and
operational reality by understanding how
to deliver quality through evals, human
review, and how you might build your
teams around that. So, a little bit
about ourselves. My name is Jeremy. I
lead product at a company called Free
Play, um, which exists to help solve a
lot of these operational problems and
and help companies ship great AI
products.
Hi everyone, my name is Chris Hernandez.
I lead our speech analytics team at
Chime. Uh, I've been in the industry for
about 10 years uh, from a CX perspective
and uh, about nine years on the ML
space. So excited to be here.
So both Chris and I kind of came from
the traditional ML world into the Gen AI
world. And I thought it was like helpful
to maybe take a note and talk about like
what we feel like has changed in this
transition. Um so I think the biggest
difference in my mind is this decreased
barrier to entry. Right? In the
traditional ML world like you need tons
of data to even get started there these
long model training cycle times and that
barrier to entry just kind of like goes
down significantly um in a gen AI world,
right? like you can now use the
intelligence of the base models to be
able to like make use of and leverage uh
smaller data assets within your
organization. And then comes along with
that is this like increased iteration
speed which is like as the barrier to
entry goes down the speed at which you
can iterate starts to go up and this
increased iteration speed starts to
accentuate the need for like a high
quality ops function. Um, so we want to
take a look at why.
Working across like dozens of different
enterprise teams at Free Play, we've
noticed this common trend emerge, which
is companies will build an initial
prototype. Maybe they'll even ship a V1
of that thing into production, but they
have inevitably hit this sort of quality
chasm as they try and go from a V1 to a
V2 that really drives true value for the
customer. And there's this reliability
problem in there.
And what we've seen is like the only way
that you really cross that quality chasm
that and get to a reliable V2 is through
iteration.
And so we talk about this iteration loop
as you move from monitoring to
experimentation to testing evaluation.
And I I use that word broadly speaking,
human review, auto evaluation, like
these things all kind of come into play.
Um, but what happens is your product
quality becomes a direct function of
your ability to move through this loop,
right? The faster you can iterate, the
more times you can move through this
loop, the better your product quality
becomes.
So it ops kind of sits at the foundation
of this and especially as you start to
scale, right? Like your ability to move
through this loops is like ends up being
an ops function. And the like not so
subtle irony here is that to deliver
high quality AI products, you actually
need a ton of human elbow grease. And
I'll pass it to Chris here to talk a
little bit more about the importance of
human experts in this process.
Cool. Awesome. Um, you know, I made the
joke that one day I was like, you know,
the first time I saw L&Ms and we started
playing around with it. You know, I
typed I'm like, uh, I wonder if it
actually knows like basic things like
who invented Wi-Fi? And then it spit out
Abraham Lincoln. I was like, "Oh my
goodness, like we're we're in some
trouble." But, uh, all jokes aside, and
maybe not that extreme, it is a good
reminder that LLMs and even the smartest
ones can make mistakes. Uh, and they
often do it with a lot of confidence.
Um, so, uh, that's of course what we
call hallucination. And in the Genai
space, um, at times like you got to make
sure that, you know, we don't leave it
unchecked and that these hallucinations
can actually be tricky and risky. Uh,
they could also mislead customers and it
could misinform decisions. And when you
think of like companies or industries
like healthcare, just a small
hallucination could have a lot of risk
in it. Um, so that's where human and
loop comes in. That's why it's important
to talk about this today. And human and
loop kind of ensures while Gen AI does
the heavy heavy lifting, uh, humans are
still there to steer the ship and and
drive in the right direction. Um, so
today we're going to talk a little bit
more about like human loop, why it's
important. I don't think this is like
groundbreaking like everyone understands
human loop. has been around forever, but
just reiterating on the importance of
it. So, LLMs right now are just, you
know, we know that they're good at uh
generating content and they do it
really, really quickly. But without
humans, they often fall short of real
world reliability, especially when
nuance, empathy, and context is
required. Without human in the loop,
you're also not scaling productivity,
you're scaling risk. And so, a single
hallucination in isolation might not
seem like a big idea or big deal, but at
scale it could be dangerous. Um so uh
the last point I want to make on that is
also each time a human flags or corrects
an output it's a signal that we need to
be using to help retrain and reinforce
the models that we see and that's of
course how uh you know models are
evolving over time. So I want everyone
to think of human in loop not as like a
safeguard it but as a feedback mechanism
or feedback engine if you will. So every
model output that goes through a human
review that feedback then gets fed for
refinement and and of course improving
the model and over time this loop brings
AI closer to real human expectations and
behaviors but there is a challenge and
and speaking with many different teams
the challenge is that we don't have
enough people to do all these reviews
like model graded eval in general are
great but you still need to have the
human element in there so most teams
don't have enough people to review
thousands of the different outputs that
you have and that makes it really really
hard to improve on the models and even
measure uh the current state of the
models that you have. But there is good
news and so this might not seem like a
clear path in some of the organizations
that you all might be be part of. Um but
we already have teams that are kind of
trained to do this type of work of human
in the loop. And those teams are like
your quality folks or CX folks within
the operations side of the business. And
so especially when you look at call
centers, they're already experts in
doing the jobs that you need them to do,
which is evaluate interactions at scale,
spotting spotting edge cases and
defining what really what good looks
like. So in this age of a genai, their
roles from my perspective is not
shrinking, it's continuing to evolve.
Um, and they're not just right, they're
not just measuring outputs anymore, uh,
or outcomes. Uh, I think they're really
shaping like the future and what's next.
So as Gen AI becomes like more embedded
in the operations, quality is also
evolving. It's no longer about auditing
what's already happened. Uh but it's
also about shaping what's going to
happen next. So the shift change uh in
the QA teams or in this ops space.
They're not just scorekeepers anymore.
They're becoming model shapers, prompt
testers, and AI performance monitors.
And if there's any group that's already
built for this kind of work, as I
mentioned before, you might want to look
at your ops team and see if there's
anyone in the QA contact centers that
could also help expand your projects uh
even further. Um they already know how
to evaluate the nuance conversations.
They also know how to surface these edge
cases like I mentioned before.
So talk a little bit about like the
evolution of just quality in general or
CX. Um they've been for the most part
focusing on auditing, coaching,
compliance. Uh but as automation
continues to scale, these roles aren't
disappearing, but they're actually
transforming. When you look back, you
know, 25 years ago, um right, you know,
the main roles were just QA
professionals were listening to phone
calls and evaluating interactions, but
we see that as like continue like a
continued evolution where automation is
now coming uh into play and these folks
are like transforming their skill sets
to help solve for larger problems.
The diagram that we have here kind of
just shows like where the QA scope is
today and how it's expanding to the Gen
AI space. At the core, we have what QA
has always done uh which is auditing
interactions, capturing quality
behaviors. But now, as you can see, we
scope the scope itself is expanding and
QA professionals are testing prompts now
and they're tagging outputs and they're
really helping shape the model uh
behavior that we're expecting. Uh and
there is a beauty in the Genai space uh
which is it opens the doors to
nontechnical folks. uh traditionally
only the ML teams, engineers are the
ones that are heavily involved in the
outputs and deciding what's going to you
know come from it. Uh but now um you
don't need to know how to build the
model pipeline to know what you know a
good output looks like. Uh just like you
don't need to know how to um make wine
to be a good wine connoisseur. Uh the
the outputs or the expertise still
matters and just as valuable. uh and
then the contact center CX teams are
again already equipped with this and so
um it might be something to to look into
and just see how you could expand that
reach even further.
So one of the things Chris is talking
about here is like something we have
observed like working across a number of
custo customers as well which is this s
sort of emerging role of like the AI
quality lead and importantly like I've
almost never seen it actually called
this but it seems to exist at companies
who are having like a lot of success in
the gen AI space and I expect this role
to actually become more formalized and
gain more traction right like Chris and
his team are an example of this role um
and importantly like people in this role
can come from a variety of different
backgrounds, product, ops, engineering,
but like the key attributes of what
makes someone a good AI quality lead is
someone who first and foremost has a
deep deep understanding of the customer
need in the domain and then importantly
is a systems thinker and is able to like
systematically think about how to
diagnose and solve these quality
problems. What that looks like daytoday
is this person is doing a lot of these
just kind of like this new skill set
labeling data writing evaluation
criteria running experiments and tests
and things like this and prompt
engineering and you'll notice that like
there is something notably missing from
that which is like these are often not
the people who are writing production
code but I think what has changed so
significantly is writing production code
is not the only way now that you can
contribute in like a really hands-on
way. All of these things like given the
right tool set and the right structure
of your team, you can contribute to like
this iteration loop, the prompt
engineering, the evaluation, all this
kind of stuff without necessarily being
the one like writing the production code
dayto-day.
Chris is talking about like how you do
this at scale, but we've also seen a lot
of success where companies will have one
person or two people in this role. Um,
especially when you have a smaller
footprint and that goes a long way, you
know. So I think what what Chris is
painting is like in larger enterprises
and as you start to scale this stuff up,
you really need like a meaningful
quality team, but you can do this by
like kind of empowering a single or
couple individuals in this role.
Cool. So I'm just going to leave you all
with a a few last points. You know, I
think while human loop is important and
like we just spent the last few minutes
talking about it, uh if you don't have
the resources, I think, you know,
looking at high-risisk, high trust areas
is abs like an absolute must. And so
insert human in the loop at decision
points and not just for show. The next
piece is like continue to bring your
like your ops teams and CX teams into
the life cycle early to help what you
know define what good looks like. Uh so
they could help build out golden sets
and uh tests against real world real
world edge cases. Um and then this is
another point I wanted to make too is
just like the the fact of like launch is
not the finish line. Uh track
performance, flag hallucination, measure
impact and iterate. uh time and time
again I see teams like celebrating which
is great to see celebration of like a
product actually launching or solution
being actually launched. Uh but the
important part there that it's not the
end it's the beginning where you need to
set up your teams to make sure that the
outputs are performing how you expect
them to perform. Um and last but not
least scale is not just about tech
anymore. I think it's about people and
so leveraging QA ops uh and support and
frontline teams I think as a strategic
partner in the Jedi space is going to be
what makes teams successful. And if
there's just one key takeaway today,
it's that scaling Gen AI isn't just a
technical challenge anymore. It's an
operational uh reliability and
responsibility. Um when you embed
quality and then human feedback into
that loop, the right people uh into your
Genai systems, you're not just building
faster, but you're also building better.
Um so anyways, thank you guys.
Appreciate it.
[Music]